and we've now reached the point in the
week shireen where we talk about the
things
we can't wait to see and i'm going to go
first this week because
i've been very excited ever since i was
reading through the transcript yesterday
of the vic fangio press conference
and i saw that he was asked a question
about
snow in the forecast in denver and i got
very excited i grabbed my phone
i checked out the excellent dark sky app
and i saw that they were
calling for seven to eleven inches they
have since revised it to three to seven
and who knows maybe over the course of
the day
they've revised it even more but i don't
care i want snow
i want a snow globe game i want that i
never expected i'd have it in october
i'm looking forward
to the tv pulling up on the big monitor
i've got here with the nbc feed of all
the games at four o'clock on sunday and
i'm looking forward to seeing the snow
fly
between patrick mahomes and the chiefs
drew lock and the broncos and we know
mahomes
loves playing in the snow i hope we get
our first snow game of the year on
sunday shireen
there is nothing like a snow game mic
not even a rain game but you like all
those it just it's
it's a throwback game right but it sure
is fun to watch so i hope they get a lot
of snow
just like they did when mahomes played
against the colts in the playoffs and
that's the first time he had ever played
in snow of course grew up here in texas
and
played at texas tech and had never
played in the snow until that game and
played awfully well
and that also will be the debut of
le'veon bell who has played plenty of
games in the snow so we might get a big
dose of le'veon bell on this game
and that would be fun too all right
serene what's first on your list what
you can't wait to see this weekend
well i just want to see if the cowboys
are going to be able to stay in the nfc
east race and you know they they have
the next two games against washington
and philadelphia and then play
pittsburgh before their bye week and if
they don't win this week i think you can
pretty much write them off because i
don't
think there's going to be enough wins on
the schedule even to get to seven wins
which might win the division i just
don't think they can do it
to me this is a must-win game for them
andy dalton said he feels much better in
the offense the second week
having gone through an entire game we'll
see he's not dak prescott
so uh he's going to face that vaunted
washington pass rush with only one
starting offensive lineman in there so
it's gonna be a tough game for him
yeah you know i have the cowboys winning
that game but what the hell do i know i
feel that way after the past couple of
weeks where everything i think i know
is flat out wrong but peter king was
making the case today for washington
winning that game
and you know it would be fitting because
once we write these teams off as when
they rise up and win and just screw up
our thought on what exactly is going on
in the nfl
this year but i could see washington
winning i think the cowboys will
but there's just so many injuries i
think they've reached that critical mass
where it's it it makes it very very
difficult to beat anyone even
the bad teams that they will be playing
i can't wait to see the titans and the
steelers and it's funny there is a tie
back to this potential snow game
because i said earlier this week if only
it would snow in nashville because
that's the only thing missing
from this old school 70s style clash
between pittsburgh and tennessee i want
to see
if the steelers can slow down derrick
henry i think he needs two or three
steps
before he can get up to full speed and
full force that's the time to get him
and surely keith butler and mike tomlin
are telling the guys
that that's the important point get to
him before
he has his maximum speed because he's
either going to run by you
or through you at that point and i could
see them swarming to him
daring ryan tannehill to beat them and
uh that that's going to be the key and
who knows maybe they completely sell out
to stop derek henry and they pay for it
in the passing game but i want to see
that steelers defense try to slow down
derrick henry
you know we had derek henry on the show
earlier this week mike we asked him
about the mvp conversation and i think
if he does well against the second rated
run defense in the league
we are going to be talking about him as
an mvp candidate because he will
have done it against one of the best run
defenses in the nfl
and i think what we consider one of the
best defenses in the nfl so if he can
even get to 100 yards titans are going
to have a really good chance to win this
game grind it out
and we'll be talking really highly about
the titans probably more so than we are
now and and concerning them to be a real
contender in the afc
all right sharing what else you got what
else are you anticipating this weekend
well i'm looking forward to jimmy g
going against the patriots again you
know he was tom brady's back up forever
didn't get to play too many games but
uh you know he played enough to to
convince the 49ers to go out and trade
for him and then give him the big
contract and you know
he he started a super bowl for the 49ers
whatever you want to say about him he
started a super bowl which a lot of
quarterbacks can't
uh say that they've done but i do want
to see how bill belichick designs that
defense to stop jimmy g
and and the 49ers this week yeah that
is going to be fascinating bill
belichick knows him
better than anyone and knows from
studying him very carefully what he can
do what he can't do
and it'll be fascinating to see what
belichick has in store for garoppolo
i can't wait to see primetime kyler i i
had said earlier this week i want more
cardinals in prime time little did i
know that we would get
more cardinals in prime time here's
russell wilson who's going to be facing
kyle murray for the third time talking
about the cardinals quarterback
he's a phenomenal football football
player he can really throw it he can
spin it he can run around i mean he's
quick as a cat he's just moving around
like crazy
i got to know him a little bit through
the draft process and got a lot of
respect for
for him and his competitiveness and
we're going to get to play against each
other for many years and it's going to
always be a lot of battle so
you know i'm proud to see just his his
work ethic and success and
doing it for doing for the shorter guys
but he's uh he's been special for sure
i interviewed both russell wilson and
colin murray in person just a couple of
hours apart
in atlanta early 2019 when kyle murray
was doing that
awkward media tour where he hadn't
decided to play football and he was
being put in a tough spot all the time
it's like they probably shouldn't have
brought him here until he knows what
he's going to do
but i was struck by the physical
difference between wilson
and murray wilson's a giant compared to
murray
you know because i i feel good around
russ because we're about the same size i
felt great around kyler
kyler was little and and is little
and is i think that makes it even more
fascinating to watch him play because he
he runs around and past and through
anyone and everyone he's got great
awareness
i i firmly believe he's got the best
combination of speed agility and
awareness the nfl's ever seen and people
were like what about lamar jackson he
doesn't have the awareness i'm talking
about awareness too
you've got to know when to get down when
to avoid contact
when to save it for the next play he has
that unlike any fast quarterback has
ever had shireen
it's so amazing mike he never takes a
hard hit
ever i mean he'll even take sacks in the
pocket and he'll just go down
and nobody even touches in him and how
the statisticians decide
who gets a sack i don't know but he
never seems to take a really hard sack
what i do want to see from kyler is
better accuracy he was
not good throwing the ball monday night
i went to that game
9-24 and if you take away and i know you
can't take
plays away i get that but he had the
80-yarder to christian kirk and he had
the 60-yarder of hopkins coming across
the middle that was really a catch and
run
other than that he was not good throwing
the ball 44 yards other than those two
long plays he was 9-24 as it was
we need to see better accuracy i know
for the season he's over 60
but on a consistent basis him throwing
the ball down the field
better accuracy throwing the football he
can make plays though that covers that
up when you win
you can run you can win you can do make
the plays when you have to even if it's
just two plays
that makes everything else go away and
you're not talking about all those
throws that you didn't make down the
field
and let me reiterate quickly something
chris sims pointed out i talked about it
earlier today with peter king on pft
live
watch his arm his throwing arm because
sims thinks that the way he's moving his
body language etc suggests he may have
something going on there
including noticing that as he came off
the field at one point he unbuckled his
chin strap
on both sides with his non-throwing hand
when your right hand's right here
you reach your left hand over to do it
there's something counterintuitive about
it it may be that he's trying to
to keep that arm low and to keep it from
hurting him any more than it is so keep
an eye on that arm on sunday night
all right time for one more real quickly
shireen what can't you wait to see on
sunday
i want to see if baker mayfield's going
to rebound ma mike we know he probably
shouldn't have played because of that
rib problem against pittsburgh he was
terrible through the early pick six to
minka fitzpatrick
is he gonna rebound for that is he gonna
become the quarterback that the browns
thought he was when they used the number
one overall pick on him
he hasn't been that yet but he still has
a chance to do that
they're four and two it doesn't feel
like they're four and two because the
two divisional games were absolutely
blowout routes that they
lost and they have beaten the bengals
once this year baker played well want to
see him play well again against the
bengals to see that they get back on the
right
track first thing i would have done this
week if i was kevin stefanski show the
remaining schedule
there are six games they should win
there's one game against the raiders who
knows there's three games they should
lose
they win those six they're ten and six
and they're going to the playoffs at a
10-6 record with seven teams making it
in the afc this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports